not sure if you heard the news but
Jerome Powell just went on the news Fed
chair and announced they're raising the
rates another three quarters of a basis
point which means 30-year mortgage rates
are still going to be eight percent can
you imagine eight percent a lot of
people in the real estate mortgage
financing business are concerned about
it however even in the midst of all this
madness there are a lot of people who
have plans of creating generational
wealth because this is the season to do
it and if that's a topic that interests
you our research team has spent hours
coming up with stories of families
Vanderbilts the big ones who made it and
kept it within the families and those
who made it and money didn't last past
three generations and we're going to
share with you what worked and what
didn't work and if this is a topic that
you that you're interested in click on
the link above or below come join me on
this webinar we'll share with you the
Insight that we got but once again go
get registered because seats are going
to get filled up I'll see you there